welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka the spider menace
that's here to bring you a full
breakdown of the new spider-man no way
home trailer the second teaser is filled
to the brim with easter eggs big reveals
and some major hints towards what's
happening in the film i also want to
give a reaction to the new look and
discuss some plot leaks on the film but
obviously i'll talk about that at the
end of the video in case you want to
avoid some of the major spoilers that
being said there will be some of the
more minor ones in the first part of the
video so if you've managed to avoid some
of the biggest reveals on the web and
don't want things ruined then i
recommend that you swing out of here
without the way there's no way back from
this point onwards now let's get into
our no way home trailer breakdown
okay so the first trailer for the movie
very much tackled the opening act of the
film it pretty much showed the
ramifications of peter's name being
revealed how it changed his life his
attempts to reverse things with the help
of doctor strange and how this
ultimately backfired and brought across
several characters from the multiverse
now as for this trailer it leans heavily
into the villains gives some of their
motivations and character beats and it
also reveals their incredible costumes
before ending on a big tease however we
start off with shots that pick up right
after the end of far from home and these
include ones that were shown in the
first teaser namely the public enemy
billboard this imagery of a half peter
half spider-man has been used several
times in the comics in order to display
his spider sense and it was also shown
on the front cover of the daily bugle
when reporting his identity reveal peter
also says that he's only had one week
where his life felt normal since he got
bit by the radioactive spider and this
is when mj found out who he was i think
the movie is very much gonna tackle mj
also forgetting his identity too and
you'll have to decide whether to bring
her back into the fold as she's clearly
being put in a lot of danger this
happens not only at the start of the
trailer when they have to jump off the
bridge but also when they swing through
the subway and she falls off the statue
of liberty at the end of the teaser now
we see strange saying that the mcu got
some visitors when peter botched the
spell but it was you made to be fair you
botched this spell now indigo with this
are images of the pumpkin bomb before
we're introduced to our first big bad
this is the green goblin who's back in
his classic costume from the first
spider-man movie and he's being reprised
once more by willem dafoe i always
thought that it kind of sucked that the
reimy movies killed off so many of the
villains as it would have been brilliant
to see osbourne appear throughout the
entire trilogy i know that harry
hallucinated seeing him in the other
movies but because of the impact he left
on the first film it just felt like
something was missing though everyone
loves stockholk for me dafoe is the
biggest villain for the film and from
what i've heard he's gonna be the main
bad guy in it there's a lot of leaks
going around on the movie and from what
i've been told his costume will go
through several changes in it firstly
when the villains arrive he'll be in his
classic one from the raimi verse that we
saw on the poster this will get damaged
and he'll end up losing the helmet from
this point out he'll lie low and pretend
to be a homeless person and he'll also
wear a poncho is it a punch shot anyway
he then traveled to feast which as we
know from far from home is run by anne
may here he'll encounter peter and he'll
tell him about the villains dying if
they go home which will set off a chain
of events that leads to peter freeing
them i'll talk about this more later on
in the plot leaks part of the video but
goblin will also get drones and he'll
wear goggles for his final look which
i'm sure you've seen if you've been
following the channel which your bloody
should have now as for the black suit
it's been confirmed now that this will
actually just be the red and black suit
turned inside out if you saw some of the
shots from the leaked alternate trailer
you'll have known for a while now that
this happens because peter gets green
paint thrown on him by a mysterio
supporter yesterday big screen leaks
revealed that the magic webs we've seen
in the toys will also be given to him by
strange and these will have the power to
send the villains back to the prison
just below the sanctorum that's a really
good idea and it makes sense as to why
he'd use these now it's also possible
that he keeps some of the nanotech and
this is how he makes the integrated suit
which looks like a cross between the
black one and the iron spider from this
point we get some extended looks at the
bridge scene namely ok fighting peter
after he likely just jumped off the car
that he suited up on this is an awesome
action scene and peter even uses double
webs as he runs away go and run you
coward now doc ock was heavily revealed
in the first trailer and he was pretty
much a thing they closed out on to blow
everyone's mind the bridge scene
actually takes place at the hudson river
which is where the character was killed
in the rainy movie so it's a nice little
callback to that now though in the first
trailer he seemed like quite a
threatening presence it seems like he's
actually trying to reason with peter in
this one which makes me think that he's
not a completely malevolent force if you
pay close attention to the differences
between this new look and the last one
you might also notice that the villain's
tentacles have changed slightly this was
shown in the empire magazine photos and
images and we saw as the tentacles went
from their normal look when he was
squeezing peter's head to having red and
gold lace throughout them i actually
have a theory that when doc holds peter
in the air that the tentacles will
absorb the nanotech in his suit and that
this then will be overtaken by the
tentacle ai this would explain why peter
doesn't really seem to be using the
integrated suit that much beyond the
bridge moment and if you look at the
trailer and images he's kind of swapping
between the red and black one and also
the black one so i think the nano tech
will be absorbed into ox tentacles and
he'll then go back to his other version
he also unmasks peter in the trailer and
is confused as to why he's not the toby
maguire version when the trailer first
released a lot of people theorized that
the person he was saying hello peter to
was actually toby but i think this
confirms that it was indeed just
holland's version now there are a lot of
teasers towards them showing up but
we'll talk about that later on towards
the end of the video now just as he has
him on the wall you can also see in slow
motion that the nanotech quickly covers
peter's chest and it looks like there's
less here potentially tying into that
theory about the nanotech being on his
tentacles there's more shots of peter
avoiding him and we also get a fun bit
in which they'll laugh about how his
name is dr octopus whilst he stands
imprisoned the aging on molina is
fantastic and you might also notice that
mj ned and peter are all in the clothes
that they had on in the first hook
images in that we watched as they snuck
down to the basement and this joking
moment in the sanctorum is a nice
juxtaposition between the fight on the
bridge now i think this moment on the
bridge is based loosely on the happy
birthday storyline in the graphic novel
we open with dormammu attacking times
square in the middle of new york strange
went to cast a spell to send him back to
the void but peter interrupted this and
it caused the multiverse to rip open in
the terror of reality he encountered two
versions of himself namely a one from
his past and a one from his future peter
realized that he could actually affect
the realities and slightly change things
potentially even stopping himself from
becoming spider-man the book ended with
him fighting lots of different villains
from across the multiverse which this
movie is of course also doing this raged
across new york city and it included all
of the villains that we've seen in the
teasers strange managed to restore
reality and with it being peter's
birthday we ended with him giving a
present which brought forth the spirit
of uncle ben ben said he was really
happy with him and also how he'd handled
his great power and responsibilities
though i don't know if this will be in
the movie i think it would be awesome to
see uncle ben and if they got a big
actor to play the part it would really
end the film on a high note now
accompanying this bridge scene is a
quick shot of the statue of liberty
which has a captain america shield this
is highly rumored to be where the final
showdown is and on it you can catch not
only a storm cloud indicating electro
but also the shield at the top and a
sign for the statue just below it i put
a yellow arrow in so you can see because
i know you miss it you idiot now later
on in the trailer we get a shot in which
peter stands on top of the statue's head
and you can also catch him holding the
cube as well there's also a blast on it
similar to the spell and my guess is
that this is the warning that strange
gives at the end when he says more
people are coming through either way
there's lots of moments of the scene in
the trailer namely the statue falling
apart and peter jumping after gwen sorry
mj mj now we also catch peter at a power
station and i'm guessing that this is
where the showdown with electro is peter
is put in charge of getting the villains
back and he has to scooby-doo this crap
we also see the opposite side of the
image from the first look and can
confirm that it is indeed strange at the
top of the stairs mj rightly points out
that this is all kind of his mess which
yeah it's just right you botched this
spell you're [ __ ] like the thumbs up
button if you think strange botched the
spell now we get some continued looks of
the sandman fight and then also a look
at someone reporting on it aka jay jonah
jameson you can see that he's brought
with him a daily bugle van it's nice to
see him actually reporting on stuff
instead of just being the editor that he
was in the comics now the trailer very
much gives us a reason as to why peter
and doctor strange end up going head to
head we very much learn that if the
villains are sent back to their home
worlds they'll be killed and that's why
don't don't turn there's no way home or
off that bridge now in their own
realities the spider-man of their
universes were responsible for their
deaths and this is why peter feels
guilty the only villain who wasn't
killed originally was sandman but from
what i've been told on the movie we will
end up learning what happened after the
events of spider-man 3. sandman
apparently says that peter forgave him
but strange will inform us that they
crossed paths years later and he was
killed during that fight take that with
a pinch of salt but it makes sense as to
why sandman is wrestling with being good
and bad the first trailer did show him
stopping an electro blast and you could
catch what looked like the pair fighting
so that just makes a lot of sense i love
how the villains are just really
fighting for their survival and that
added humanity we get in this new look
is great it just really helps to flesh
out why peter is desperate to say them
there's also a giant sand fist and this
is of course very reminiscent of the
comics in which sandman would often use
that as his main attack now in the first
trailer we got a good look at the
magical cube and in this we learn more
about how it's holding the villains in
place at the sanctorum prison peter will
steal this and this will make strange
chase him across new york and then into
the mountains on the back of a train i
love how there's this real conflict
between them and strange is of course
obsessed with protecting reality whereas
peter very much just wants to protect
life it's a great conflict between them
and throughout the fight we're gonna see
things like the cape grabbing peter and
so on now we get a shot of electro and i
absolutely love the upgrade that they've
given to jamie foxx from what i've been
told the character will warp into the
mcu and it'll be very reminiscent of the
opening of a terminator film in which
the killer robot arrives this will be at
a power plant which is where he'll steal
an engineer's jacket and then he'll get
rid of this to don what we see in the
trailer the mask looks amazing and it's
very reminiscent of its look in the
comics but they've upgraded it to make
it so that it's electricity that creates
it instead of it just being cloth you
might also notice that they've changed
the coloring of his electricity from
blue to yellow this is more in line with
the comics too and it further brings
things closer to the way that the live
action characters are presented in the
mcu
now there's a lot more action shots and
we see the three villains namely sandman
electro and the lizard the villain will
once more be played by recipients who
i'm sure you know from the amazing
spider-man series in that dr kirk
connors had lost his arm and he was
trying to use the healing factor of
lizards in order to find a way to
regenerate his limb however this
backfired and though it grew back it
turned him into a giant hulking lizard
at the same time now what i love about
connors and well most of the villains in
this trailer is that he's somewhat of a
tragic character i was absolutely
obsessed with him in the 90s cartoon as
it just fascinated me watching his arm
grow back and then him changing to this
hulking beast now there's a moment which
the three villains swing forward and if
you look closely you'll see that the
lizard gets hit by something but it's
been cgi'd out i have no idea what this
is but if i had to hazard a guess i'd
say that it's andrew garfield and
they've just removed him for this first
look very strange moment but yeah
definitely something worth paying
attention to now we get a moment which
mj falls and peter jumps after her not
only is this a slight call back to one
of the illusions and far from home but
it's very reminiscent of the death of
gwen stacy from the amazing spider-man
2. that moment also pulled from the
comics in which the green goblin threw
gwen off the side of the brooklyn bridge
peter caught here but she died from
either the impact of the fall or because
the breakneck speed of the web was
literally breakneck not good not a good
pun that anyway he wrestled with the
guilt over this for some time and i love
how this kind of hints towards the comic
storyline and garfield's films it would
be pretty wild if mj died at this moment
and hopefully she survives the fall
now strange very much hints towards
other people coming through the portal
and i think this will of course be toby
maguire and andrew garfield the trailer
was very much about showcasing the
villains and i think that they would
have teased other ones if it was someone
like a venom or so on in the
post-credits scene of let there be
carnage he was brought to the mcu so we
kind of already know that his entrance
wasn't in this scene so i'm really
hoping that we get to see them all come
together but unfortunately this trailer
doesn't end the debate of whether
they're in the film or not though it
does definitely tease it
now as i mentioned earlier i think this
might be happening when we see the blast
come out from the statue of liberty and
that kind of ties into the portal
opening up and then them coming across
also you probably notice that there's
lots of scaffolding at the location and
not to go too far into what's been
leaked but yeah andrew garfield is
indeed the werewolf because this is the
exact same scene now i'm recording this
at 1 30 a.m in the morning and i'm also
about to head to edinburgh in six hours
just to take some time out so i will be
back with another video in the week to
just talk about all the easter eggs that
i missed in this one because i'm sure
there's a few i've not had coffee guys
just let me be i've tried to be as
thorough as possible but yeah make sure
you let me know in the comments below if
there's anything i missed and i'll be
sure to cover it on the next video now
for the next two parts of the video i
want to do my reaction first and then we
can get into more of the plot leaks i
thought i'd switch the order i normally
do as you might just want to hear my
thoughts but not any of the spoilers for
the film anyway i absolutely love the
way that the movie is shaping up to be
and if they manage to stick the landing
on this then it could be one of the best
comic book movies of all time spider-man
is one of the medium's most popular
characters and he's right up there next
to batman and superman in terms of
stature and legacy the character has had
a number of amazing films and his rogues
gallery is arguably one of the best as
well to have this all coming together
for the movie makes it feel like an epic
for a number of reasons director john
watts recently told empire magazine that
this movie feels like spider-man end
game and it certainly comes across that
way i think it's gonna be absolutely
filled with easter eggs and i can't wait
to see what happens when the movie is
released they're really putting
everything they can into it and i think
it's going to be one of the biggest
movies of all time even with the
pandemic people are just desperate to
see it and sony have actually made
people hungry for it by holding off on
the marketing because they know that if
they keep some secrets then the hype is
just gonna be even higher it's a great
second trailer and the two of these
together are absolutely amazing teasers
for a film that i really can't wait to
see now as hyped as i am i have to keep
a balanced head and i know that because
of everything that's going on in this
movie that there is a chance it's gonna
suck they really have to deal with the
cliffhanger from far from home introduce
the new villains characters and also
have a great story too so it doesn't
feel like we're just watching fight
scene after fight scene with the
villains of yesteryear it's going to be
difficult but marvel have shown us time
and time again that they're up to the
challenge and i can't wait to see it
when this movie releases now that takes
us onto the leaks part of the video and
full spoilers ahead from this point
onwards leaks like this should be taken
with a pinch of salt but some stuff does
seem to be what happens in the two
trailers so just know that i won't be
casting a spell to make you forget if
you go past this point it's your own
bloody fault you should have stopped the
video you [ __ ] now the opening of sorry
about that now the opening of the movie
is pretty much what we've seen in the
teasers with peter being bombarded in
new york after the end of far from home
he then swings through the city with mj
as it's plastered everywhere that he's
public enemy number one peter escapes
and ends up handing himself in which is
when matt goes to his defense and gets
him off mysterio's story doesn't really
hold up in court and though peter's name
is cleared it doesn't mean he has an
easy life everyone knows his name at
this point and there's still some that
believe mysterio because a fake news
wouldn't be published as much as it is
if people weren't willing to still
believe it thus he goes to doctor
strange who casts a spell to make the
world forget peter interrupts this and
it then breaks the multiverse open which
is when the villains from across the
multiverse come into the mcu these
include doc oak the green goblin sandman
electro and the lizard it's a real
doctor shaktipus and they start to
attack new york which is when we get the
bridge scene during this time norman
osborne decides to lay low and the other
villains go wild strange and peter
managed to capture them and they put
them in a prison below the sanctum
sanctorum strange wants to send them
back to their home worlds but he has to
figure out first where they are and how
to do this norman then visits them and
they all recall their deaths which
spider-man was present at osborne
realizes that he needs the villains in
order to carry out his plan but
strange's magic is too strong so he goes
to peter in the guise of an ally he says
that because they all died on their
worlds that sending them back would be a
death sentence and he also blames the
peta of their universes for their demise
peter knows what it's like to be wiped
from existence because of the snap and
he doesn't want to put anyone else
through that this guilt peter into
stealing a magical cube from strange
that frees the villains and allows them
all to escape this is when strange
chases peter through the mirror
dimension and we see new york collapsing
around them strange finally captures him
but it's too late and thus they've got
to stop osbourne before he carries out
his plan now i have heard that the
villains in the movie namely the ones
who turned good actually now have a chip
in their head that controls them to some
extent this may be developed from the ai
tech in doc's tentacles but that is just
me guessing however sandman doesn't have
this because he's basically sand and as
we know sand it just gets everywhere
this is why we saw him helping peter in
the trailer against electro and you know
the guy he's not he's not that bad he
just killed uncle ben for his daughter
so let the guy off and there's also some
big blowout battles and osborne ends up
creating a giant arc reactor that he
positions over the statue of liberty
this has a captain america shield on it
and it makes for an amazing set piece
unfortunately from what i've heard ant
made dies during the movie and we close
out with a film feeling very tragic
according to leaks on the film the
post-credits scene contains tom hardy's
venom and then as we head into his third
film that will kind of be where his
story picks up from now apparently there
have been multiple endings filmed
similar to endgame and this is to stop
the spectacular spoiler man himself tom
holland from letting things slip we will
see when the movie releases just how
true these leaks are but if you've been
following the channel for a while now
you'll know most stuff is pretty much 50
50 and even when the leaks are very
close to what's in the final thing there
are still some aspects that are wrong
either way i'm guessing that this is the
last big trailer we'll get and the next
looks will be mostly made above tv spots
and the odd new bit of footage hopefully
though you enjoyed the video and of
course let me know your thoughts below
on what you want to see when the movie
releases if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our breakdowns linked on screen right
now might be better
probably worse let's be honest but i
hope to see you over there after this if
not then thanks for sitting through this
video i've been poor you mean the best
and i hope you enjoy the rest of your
week take care peace
you